millennium fandom bar off las vegas
boulevard has opened once again
due to being closed due to the pandemic
tonight they're celebrating may the 4th
by throwing an opening night party in
honor of star wars
madison kimbrough went to check it out
right before doors opened and has the
latest
yes that's right we're here at
millennium fandom bar and as you can see
i'm standing in front of a live
model of r2d2 as they get ready for the
festivities happening tonight
may the fourth be with you is the theme
of tonight as star wars fans can come
out and enjoy opening night
the bar which was created by fans for
fans of animation
anime books comics and cosplay and so
much more is honoring the worldwide pop
culture phenomenon
by making it a themed star wars night
from drinks to artwork to pop-up photo
booths to movies playing in the
background
it's sure to be a good time it's the day
where
all the fan of star wars can come out
and dress up and come have a drink and
cheers to the main character of star
wars and then you're gonna be able to
come to talk about
the franchise from the last 40 years and
the new the old one the new tv series
mandalorian
it's free to get in and people are
encouraged to dress up as their favorite
character
moving forward millennium fandom bar
will be open wednesdays through
saturdays
from 5 p.m to 2 a.m on the weekends
and this is sure to be a fun night
celebrating everything star wars doors
will be open until
2 a.m reporting from millennium fandom
bar madison kimbrough
8 news now